personne cité héroïque les affiches qui
le proclament tapissent la route qui
mène au centre de la ville qui a été
occupée par la Russie pendant 9 mois
mais si beaucoup ont résisté à ces mois
d'occupation russe aujourd'hui il
partent
l'immense joie de tétiana quand elle a
vu arriver les soldats Ukrainiens tant
attendu fait place à la peur
sont intenses dans notre quartier
dit-elle la nuit dernière ils ont tiré
sans arrêt les obus sont tombés tout
près c'est pour ça qu'on doit partir
elle quitte sans son beau-fils
il ne faut pas laisser que des
vieillards dans la ville croient-il mais
il n'en n'est pas moins terrorisé par
les bombardements qui n'a pas tort mais
c'est il est mort tout le monde peut
préservé mais c'est un nouvel an faire
qui enveloppe la ville depuis la déroute
de la Russie depuis la river orientale
du ni pro où ils sont retranchés ces
soldats pylon Herson sans merci
Pacha comprend bien les risques que
prennent chacun de ceux qui s'accrochent
à leur terre il allait à vélo quand une
pluie de tir s'est abattue tout autour
de lui
il vise les civils ils savent bien nos
soldats sont postés racontent le jeune
homme mais il ne les cible pas il tire
sur les civils comme ça Victor lui
rentrait à peine à la maison quand il a
été sonné par une explosion
ou les la mort ça reste mieux que de
vivre sous le joug des soldats de
Vladimir Poutine dit-il
ils allaient de maison en maison il
volait il tuait se rappelle-t-il et ils
emmenaient les gens dans les sous-sols
c'est un mot qui est devenu synonyme de
torture en Ukraine partout où les Russes
sont passées
de la ville un résistant lui aussi qui a
défié les ordres de la nouvelle
administration russe aussi longtemps
qu'il a pu de mars à septembre il a
dirigé son petit hôpital en y cachant
les soldats Ukrainiens blessés ils
étaient enregistrés comme de simples
civils il a aussi déjoué la volonté de
l'occupant de transformer son
établissement en hôpital militaire pour
l'armée de Vladimir Poutine quand les
soldats sont arrivés il avait mis en
scène une éclosion majeure de covid
combinaison de protection et affiche à
l'appui mais les Russes en ont
finalement de son entêtement et sont
venus l'arrêter c'est en prison qu'il a
été témoin de leur cruauté
il donnait des électrochocs dans le
jargon de la prison il disait qu'il
passait un coup de fil à zelingski
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est une électrode
qui est placée sur l'oreille et une
autre sur le scrotum puis il déclenche
le courant électrique s'il est un héros
alors c'est un héros bien ordinaire à
Epson diléonid rappelant que sa ville a
d'abord tenu tête au chat russe des
foules de manifestants ont tenté de leur
barrer la route montant sur les chars en
criant aux Russes de rentrer chez eux
les images de ces démonstrations de
bravoure ont largement contribué à
galvaniser le sentiment patriotique des
Ukrainiens Léonie de remiga Y a puisé la
force de résister aux Russes quoi qu'il
en coûte
le directeur de l'hôpital ne branche
plus au son des explosions les Russes se
vengent dit-il
depuis le retrait des Russes plus de 30
personnes sont mortes sous les tirs de
l'armée russe il meurt à la maison en
circulant dans la rue à la recherche
d'eau au hasard d'un quotidien accaparer
par la survie à ces circonstances ajoute
une arme redoutable dans l'arsenal de la
Russie l'hiver le froid en se retirant
ils ont détruit la majorité des
infrastructures ici on travaille
d'arrache-pied pour établir
l'électricité et l'eau potable la très
vaste majorité des habitations de ceux
qui restent sont sans chauffage
la Vie dans la Cité des héros est
épuisante on vient chercher de l'eau on
se rue sur la distribution de nourriture
et de quoi se défendre du froid ce
camion est rempli de couverture et
autres dons envoyés directement du
Canada un peu partout en ville de
grandes tentes chauffées permettent aux
habitants de recharger leur téléphone de
se brancher sur un monde dont ils
étaient coupés de reprendre un peu de
force un combat de chaque instant dont
on s'accommode la liberté ditant ici
vaut bien toutes les misères tous les
dangers ici marie-eveda Radio-Canada
Helson